When I was growing up, I definitely wanted to be a pilot,...
...and I still actually think about it day-to-day.
I think about taking lessons or something,...
...but I like being on the ground, it's safer.
I created Instagram.
Instagram actually grew out of a company we had started before.
That didn't work out so well.
No one was using it, but...
...the one feature they were using was posting photos.
And they were using apps, other apps to filter their photos,...
...and we realized there was a pattern there.
So we decided to build it all together in one app...
...and see what people would do.
The first day we had over 25,000 sign-ups,...
...so it was really exciting for us.
There isn't so much an "aha" moment as...
...this feeling that if we didn't do this idea,...
...someone else was going to.
And we realized the power of mobile photography and the opportunity at hand...
...and what was to come in the coming year...
...with all the cameras that were being installed on all these phones,...
...and how many people would love taking photos with their smartphones.
That was something we wanted to capture.
I left my job to start a startup because that's what I wanted to do.
It was a long slog actually,...
...we had been working about a year before Instagram came around.
But once we had the idea, it was about eight weeks until we launched...
...and obviously the rest is history now.